a quarter million homes and businesses
still have no power today after
wednesday's powerful wind storm in the
great plains and the upper midwest the
storm packing hurricane-force winds left
at least five people dead in the area it
came just days after the deadly
tornadoes that ripped across kentucky
and several other states lilia luciano
is in dawson springs kentucky where the
cleanup has been going on now for days
and still has many weeks to go lilia
nobody wants to hear that good morning
to you
that's right gail and here at least in
kentucky at least 75 people have died
because of the devastating tornado in
some areas power may not be restored for
at least a month and for many of those
survivors a new reality is just now
starting to settle in
for the clark family home is now just a
room
one room for a family of six and three
dogs
honestly it's been pretty
rough
we're used to a big two-story house a
house that was destroyed by last
friday's tornado along with almost all
of their possessions clothes bank cards
even their cars were totaled that's our
car stuck up on that tree now the clarks
are staying at this repurposed lodge
inside pennyrel forest state park it's
become a shelter housing more than 100
people
at this point i think the shock of what
has happened is starting to wear off and
it's more it's being replaced by fear of
what's next will adams is the deputy
commissioner of kentucky state parks at
some point you know they're worried
about where am i going to move to you
know where's the housing that sort of
thing now the clerks are relying on
donations and the efforts of people like
kami king
jump one two three oh these are my
friends how are you live a preschool
teacher at the local school
and these are all just items that i've
had donated in the last two days her
classroom became a hub for donations
we're not just there for your child
we're there to provide a service for
your entire family dawson springs school
is still here we're stronger than ever
and we're going to rebuild but even with
the support of their neighbors the
clerks say the devastation may be too
great to overcome do you have family or
anyone who can pick you up and fit you
with them
no not really no
my whole family's in dawson so
everybody lost their own homes yeah
we're hoping to stay in dawson i'd
rather stay in dawson
but
honestly at this point we don't have
many options
state officials say more than 600 people
are now sheltered in those seven parks
in the state many people are in the same
situation as that family and we spoke to
that pre-k teacher that preschool
teacher what she says is that now she's
starting to worry about the community's
mental health she says this area is so
prone to severe weather and all she can
think of is how those children and their
parents are going to start reacting when
they hear thunder or strong winds like
the ones we've been having over the last
two days tony
yeah the recovery goes on lilia thank
you great reporting this week from a
tough story out of kentucky